you were offered the role of black widow
in the marvel series
yeah and that's a great role for uh
scarlett johansson but that would have
been a great role for you too
and an a slam dunk big role
but you had to turn it down because
you're so [ __ ] busy that you were
doing
gulliver's travels at that point no no
no i i
actually do want to clean up the story
on college troubles i was contracted
to do gulliver's travels i didn't want
to do gullibus travels it was a bit of a
heartbreaker for me because
i take such pride in the decisions that
i make and it they mean
so much to me the films that i do so
that was that was tough i don't even
understand how that happens because you
do devil wears prada
the studio says we'll give you this film
but you've got to promise
promise us you'll do another film and
make that decision in a certain amount
of time is that is that the
idea of it yeah and they kind of have a
bit of a hold over you so
there were other movies that i would
want to do and i'd say but i really want
to do this
movie about young victoria and so at
some point
i think it just became evident that i
needed to get rid of this optional
picture deal because it was going to
just hang over me for a long time
and i didn't want that and
ultimately as hard as it was i don't
think anyone expected for
the hand to be forced i think you kind
of like hope that it isn't
but it was yes i i care deeply
very very much about the choices i make
that's all i have
are the choices that i make because
after that it's it's really left up to
the gods like what happens you
you usually don't really have any idea
why a movie catches fire and why it
doesn't
but no i'm never left with a feeling of
regret when i turn something down
it is i know in 20 pages if i love it if
i
it's ethereal as to why i like it i
don't know why i like it i just love it
and i'm in or i'm out after 20 pages
so when you show up on the set of
gulliver's travels because you're a
professional you're going to do the best
you possibly can for sure
yeah of course no i was never looking
like a slap dance on set i'm not i would
never ever do that
and no no one knew and i also didn't
talk about it
with anyone on set or anything because
there are a lot of lovely people in it
who were
heaven to work with then i actually had
it had a really good time i had a laugh
with all of them
but it irked my heart to
for it to have happened in the first
place but i ended up trying to i
will always try and make the best of any
situation for sure